التأخير في طوابير طويلة وإلغاءات
السفر في أوروبا لم تشعر أبدًا
بالفوضى ،
واحدة من أفضل الطرق لتظهر
لك المشكلات حقًا هي اصطحابك في رحلة
سنمر بها عبر أحد أسوأ
المطارات المعطلة في العالم وإلى
واحد من  أكثر وجهات العطلات ازدحامًا
للذهاب إلى إيبيزا إسبانيا
وسرعان ما واجهنا
التحدي الأول ، فنحن في وقت مبكر جدًا
ولسنا الوحيدين ، ما هي
المشكلة
بمجرد فتح حقيبة تسجيل الوصول ، هذه هي
قائمة الانتظار
الآن ، ستكون نصيحتي عادةً  لا
تسجل في حقيبة هذا الصيف إلا إذا كنت مضطرًا حقًا إلى ذلك ، ولكن بدافع الفضول ، سنقوم بفحص أحدها على أي حال ، وفي
الواقع سأضع جهاز تعقب GPS
فيه حتى تتمكن من معرفة مكان
تتبع الحقيبة  فكرة جيدة
بشكل خاص من خلال مطار هيثرو ،
أدى نقص معالجات الأمتعة إلى
مشاهد مثل هذه الجبال من
حقيبة
الأمتعة المفقودة وداعًا ، آمل أن أراك في
إيبيزا إذا كانت قائمة انتظار تسجيل الوصول
تبدو سيئة في
هذا لم أرَ طابورًا مثل  هذا ل
الأمان ، أنا قلق بصدق من أنني
سأفوت رحلتي على الرغم من
حقيقة أنني وصلت مبكراً بثلاث ساعات
، لم يُسمح لي بتسجيل الدخول في حقيبة إلا
قبل ساعتين من الرحلة ولكن
قائمة الانتظار هذه تسير على طول الطريق من الأمن
إنها تلتف على طول الطريق ، ثم
تعود إلى أسفل
طريق مدخل المطار
إلى الزاوية البعيدة
[موسيقى] في
غضون ساعة واحدة
والمسار السريع
يقترب جدًا من موعد المغادرة ، لذلك لا يوجد وقت
لتسارع المتجر إلى البوابة  فقط لتجد أن الأمر قد
تأخر ، ولكن هناك بوابتان في الأسفل ،
هناك تأخر في رحلة الطيران لأكثر من
14 ساعة ، ينام هؤلاء الفتيات والعديد من الفتيات الأخريات
هنا في المطار ، ينام أطفالي
على الأرض ،
إنه
يشعر بالبرد ،
أطفالي ، نعم ، إنه أمر سيئ حقًا ،
نعم أنا  لقد تعبت أيضًا من
مشاكل رحلة هذين الزوجين التي بدأت حتى قبل ذلك ببدء رحلتي
في دبلن قبل يومين
وتم
إلغاء معركتي الأولى
ثم بدأت رحلتي أمس إلى
لندن الثانية والآن
تم إلغاء هذه الرحلة أيضًا  أنا الآن
هنا وآمل أن أغادر
البلد اليوم ، فهل ستسافر مرة أخرى
ليس
إلى المملكة المتحدة
، لقد تأخرت في السفر لمدة ساعة ،
لكن يبدو أن هذا صغير
مقارنة بالآخرين
، ومن المثير للدهشة أن حقيبتي جعلت الأمر على ما يرام
بالطبع يمكن أن يحدث خطأ عندما
أعود إلى المنزل
ربما يجب أن أبقى هنا